i'm shocked it's not that i was hoping
you'd come in here and you'd say
oh my but i thought you know i know
chris
and you know he gets anxiety he deals
with he has this
you know he has an anxiousness that i
have and he deals with certain demons
and um then i go we'll add into the
equation
a new baby boy and add an equation the
show
this is us just was uh cancelled well
not canceled it's always been
that's well they've been saying cancel
but it just hasn't it's as if season six
is
always so next year this yeah right the
next season will be the last season and
that is where dan fogelman has always
wanted to end
so you always knew this show was gonna
end after six seasons yeah
yeah i mean i don't know if i believe
you no no
we've all he says that but as a creator
you can only go so far because the
studio might jump in and say no we want
another season
oh so you probably were thinking sure
that we're going to get another season
he doesn't want it we were maybe we were
hoping maybe we were hoping
right or maybe i thought it was the
greatest negotiating tactic of all time
on dan's part for you know at season
three being like no no i only want to do
something it's a jedi mind trick yeah
yeah
um no no because he's told us the ending
of this show we know the ending you know
the end
we know how the ending do people die um
i mean everyone dies michael that's an
ambiguous answer
well i mean but that's the kind of the
point of of
the show is it goes back and forth in
time to show you
a time before people are born and a time
after people are dead and and the fact
that the world continues
and these relationships continue um
and i know this we've already shot
scenes
from the final episode did you cry i
wasn't part of them but we
the the the production has has
captured scenes for the final episode
did people cry people cried yeah people
people cry people always cry it's this
is will you cry
you you're not done filming no we have a
whole we have a whole another season
you have a whole other season shoot yeah
to shoot oh well i mean
that's not that's not cancellation
that's a whole season to go here no
that's what i mean that's what i'm
saying
how many episodes 18 more to go 18 more
to go
do you already start thinking about your
next job you know what
i do yes there are
there are things i'm trying to put into
the lineup
for a year and a half from now um but as
you know
that that is always a guessing game um
but i do know this i've never been
sentimental for the ending of things
because i it doesn't it doesn't ever
feel like an ending you know it doesn't
like the ending of our podcast i was
like okay
this only means that that things are
about to evolve
right